hi there it's day five of the 90 day
challenge
um one of the questions that i'm often
asked and it came up again in uh
comments to my video from yesterday is
you know i always say
reading and listening is key to
understanding or to key to to learning a
language and people say well how can you
listen to something you don't understand
and this is obviously a problem because
when you begin you don't know you don't
understand the language and so how can
you listen and read when you don't
understand
and i think there's sort of two
scenarios one is at the very beginning
of
language
and the second is when you are
stretching yourself now to listen to
things that are difficult for you
so at the very beginning whether i'm
using something like
teach yourself which is where i began
with korean and there i have the text
and i have the vocabulary and i have
some explanations so i listen i don't
understand i look up the vocabulary i
read some explanations and then i listen
again and i kind of half understand and
even after
weeks with this teach yourself i'm still
having trouble understanding the same
spots but my brain is gradually getting
used to it i understand more and more
now when you go to more advanced stuff
it's the same thing again you're taking
yourself out of your comfort zone
which you were in with that beginner
material where you kind of have
understood it and you're now pushing
yourself to try to listen to things that
are more interesting but more difficult
again you don't understand
i don't enjoy
say watching a movie where i don't
understand i don't enjoy listening when
i don't understand at all
and i have no opportunity no chance to
understand
uh some people may like doing that
having the language on in the background
and not understanding anything i don't
so i always want a transcript i want a
text because if i have the transcript or
the text i can read it i can look up
words and i can listen again and again
and slowly i'll understand more and more
of it i won't necessarily understand it
all but it doesn't matter when i'm tired
of it whether i understand 30 50 70
i move on to something else because the
words that i'm having trouble
understanding and the phrases they're
going to show up again and of course now
that we have link which we didn't really
have we didn't have korean on link six
years ago or whenever it was seven or
eight years ago i tend to use link so
i'm going to give you a bit of a
demonstration of what i do when i um
approach
you know or try to understand whether
listening or reading
texts that are too difficult for me
which is something that i feel we have
to do i should add i don't believe in
this that you're always going to read
something that only has five three
percent new words you'll be forever
acquiring the necessary vocabulary i
feel you have to attack more difficult
texts listen to them read them
accept the fact that they're going to
remain fuzzy for a long long time but in
this way gradually you're training your
brain
to understand and get used to the new
language
so this is where i
come when i open up link you'll notice
that
i'm on the learn page as it's called the
first question you know people ask me
well how can you listen to stuff that
you don't understand well first of all
here there are a number of courses
recommended to me and i can choose to go
to something that's intermediate which
has 187 new words for me or
this is intermediate 1 with 254 new
words or
there are there's even advanced stuff
that i've tried here
uh intermediate or beginner so useful
expressions for beginners so i can
choose just how hard i want to make
things for myself and
and i vary it this one here for example
is is low intermediate almost high
beginner i've spent some time there
there's no more new words there i don't
necessarily understand at all
um
but uh here's one that i noticed that
has nine roses so other people like this
course
so before i open it up here i should
also point out a few other things here
we have the learn page is where you
learn exchange is where you can ask for
help find tutors have your writing
corrected find friends and this is just
a handy list of the various things that
you can do it's sort of a shortcut these
are the various lessons that i've been
studying or i can post a request to have
something corrected or i can join a
conversation i can import a lesson from
the internet or i can review my
vocabulary you'll notice here that my
avatar which is kind of an indication of
my progress
shows that i've become more active than
i was
i've been able to acquire a bunch of
artifacts for my avatar and here is sort
of a
progress snapshot which shows that i've
been linking pretty heavily compared to
my targets
but i don't do a lot of flash carding so
i haven't yet moved my links to learned
links are my saved words but i will be
doing so
and we'll get into that later on i can
also flash card the
most frequently used words that i have
saved so far but let's leave all of that
and let's go now
into
uh one of the lessons
all right so we'll open this one here
because it's new to me
so this is you know talking to random
people so we'll open one lesson in this
course
and uh so you'll see right away right
off the bat that there are a lot of blue
words and these are all the words here
that are new to me that i haven't seen
before in fact there's only 17 words
here that i've previously saved
and that is partly because i've been
listening to a lot of
sort of politics and economics and that
kind of thing whereas here we have more
of a casual
conversation
so the question is you know obviously if
i listen to this i'm not going to
understand it very well
pretty hard for me so the question is
how can you deal with
listening to stuff that you don't
understand well
i might listen to it once not understand
very much there's about two minutes here
and then i'm gonna go through it and i'm
going to look up okay this is a person's
name so i just x that i don't want that
there's another person's name
but uh here
awkward all right i'll take that i hit
return
and uh i you know i go through that
and i save all the words
that i want to learn so i go through
first of all converting all these blue
words
into yellow words because the yellow
words are words now that i'm trying to
learn and with the yellow words i get
examples of them and a whole bunch of
stuff so i will go through this and i
will convert all of the blue words to
yellow
then i will go to my ipad and i will
read it and i with my ipad touch screen
i can look up all the yellow words
read through it so i've now read through
it and got a sense of what it means
if i then go away and listen without
reading i won't understand it so i might
read it again while listening
and i might move on before i fully
understand this
but
if i keep doing this
even if i don't understand this text i
will gradually start to understand these
new texts better and better
uh so that's kind of uh you know showing
you how how things work here at link and
now uh all these words that i've now
converted to yellow i can actually look
up and see a list of them i can flash
card them i can do different things to
help me get the hang of these words and
yet still when i listen i won't
understand but i know from experience
that gradually i will understand
better